you know how you see things in astronomy
is there Improvement or do we have a
long road to go I think it's a bit of
both I think there's been significant
Improvement in
emerging at the senior level as well I'm
overall positive and if I look even
around the physics department where I
work overwhelmingly the largest number
of women are in the air at the subfields
of astronomy compared to other areas of
physics now that's not to say shouldn't
be working harder across physics but I
think astronomy is doing pretty well but
I don't think we shouldn't feel too
complacent because I think there are
still challenges and we're still not
represented fully but I'm also realizing
as a white woman there's an issue with
lack of representation of women there's
a much actually larger issue of
representation across border racial and
other diversity